welcome today
uh on strange loop chats we're talking
with felina hermans who is the associate
professor
at the leiden institute of advanced
computer science at leiden university
and um she has previously spoken at
strange lube twice
uh and she did a keynote in 2019
yeah 2019 um and
but today i wanted to talk um first with
her about her
new book which is called the
programmer's brain so
i did get uh the advanced uh early
access
version of it and so i've read the first
part of it
and i really love the way that the book
is um
organized um so maybe you could just
talk about the four parts of the book
and
give a little overview of the content of
it
yeah absolutely so the programmer's
brain is about what happens in your in
your brain when you program
and it's basically a very brief
introduction into cognitive science but
then really
meant for people that are programming
clearly all the knowledge about
cognitive science you could learn it
from any other general interest book
but my book is really specifically aimed
at programming and
people that are doing programming as a
job so
the first part of the book is really
about in detail
what happens in your brain if your
program and specifically we zoom in
into what happens in your brain if you
read code because if you read a piece of
code that's really hard
then often and you don't really know
what to do right you read
code maybe it's because you want to use
a library on github you're like oh let's
see what the code does or
maybe it's code you yourself wrote a few
months ago
and you look at the code that's like oh
what does this do
you're confused and it makes you a bit
unhappy because you don't want to be
confused you want to straight
understand what's going on so then if
you understand your own confusion a
little bit better then
you can also deal with it a bit better
and then later on in the book we also
talk about
specifically about how to write code
that is less confusing for other people
and then we also talk about the acts of
programming so just sitting down and
programming what happens then
and all the way at the end of the book
we also talk about how
you as a more senior programmer can deal
with the confusion
of junior programmers people that are in
your team
and are maybe still getting to know the
programming language or getting to know
the code base
because there's also things you can do
to make sure other people are less
confused
i really like that it starts with like
really practical
sorts of problems and then um
sort of gets into the cognitive
psychology or the
sort of goes a level deeper into the
sort of
brain parts of it and things like that
and it reminds me of
a few other books but like certainly
like thinking fast and slow
um is uh it reminds me of all sorts of
things like that so
um i i'm really uh there's a lot of like
studies and there's a lot of
uh you know actual work it's time to
it's not just uh
uh you know i think this is how things
work or
it's actually backed up by a lot of
detail and so um that's
that's excellent um so let me just ask
you a leading question about the first
part of the book which is all about
reading code
how does how does memory affect how we
read and understand code
yeah that's a great question because
there are already many parts to the
answer to that question
so it isn't just memory is memory there
are a few parts to your memory
this is also what we explain of course
in book in more detail firstly there's
your
long-term memory this is what you have
already stored all the things you know
all the things for example you know
about java syntax
but also all the things you know about
how java programs are typically
organized
all that is long-term memory then
there's also also short-term memory and
that's what you can
remember like the first few three or
four words that you read
will be stored in your short term memory
and then finally there's also your
working memory and your working memory
is like
where you're thinking happens and there
is sort of this
idea in programming that long-term
memories doesn't really matter
people say things like oh programmers
are people with good googling skills
right
you don't have to know syntax you can
just look everything up
so we sort of downplay the influence of
long-term memory a little bit
however the more you know the easier it
is to process something
if you you have to read text in dutch
assuming you don't know dutch of course
then this is really hard for you because
maybe every other word you have to look
up some words
are very similar and the grammar is
similar so you can do some guessing but
you
you have to look up many words and that
makes it really
hard and slow to read something even
though you are a proficient reader in
another language
this is sort of the same for programming
if you're really familiar with a
programming language
or with specific programming constructs
or a library or
domain then it gets really easy to read
code but if you lack that understanding
then your long-term memory can really
get in the way
of your short-term memory because for
you remembering a few dutch words will
be really hard because you don't really
know their meaning so it's hard to store
them in your memory
so that's really what the book talks
about but the influence of your
long-term memory
on how your short-term memory and
working memory work
i i work on the closure programming
language of my day job and so
i spend a lot of time i actually spend
most of my time reading other people's
code
a lot of time in particular reading
modifications to existing codes a lot i
read a lot of diffs and patches and
things like that
um i don't i don't think that's actually
covered explicitly in the book but i'm
wondering if you have any thoughts about
um you know things that might be
different if you're like
what i find is i'm i'm trying to
recreate
the mental model of the other
of the person who wrote the change or
the code and try to re-walk
the same path that they were walking um
definitely so chapter six in the book
actually talks about mental modes
so it is very true that if you've
written code then you have a mental
model and this
sometimes might even be the wrong mental
model but especially if
code moves without you being there to do
the moves
then indeed it can be the case that you
have certain assumptions
that are no longer true or that of
course the person that
reads the code makes assumption based on
those assumptions
makes additions that later turn out not
to be true
so mental models is a little bit further
in the book we definitely talk about
what what is a mental model how do
mental models
transfer from one programming language
to the other programming language or one
concept
to the other concept and that is indeed
definitely what's happening
if code is modified by someone else then
it might
your mental model might be outdated and
then it takes some time and energy of
your working memory also to recreate
that mental model
[Music]
uh well one thing i've been thinking
about for a long time is
like when you learn and play an
instrument or you learn to
play a sport or something like that um
we have lots of
uh ways to intentionally practice those
things like we have uh
hundreds of years of tradition of how to
you know intentionally practice
those kinds of things we don't i feel
like we don't really have that for
programming like do what how do you
intentionally practice code reading as a
skill
yeah so that is very true and this is
also the arguments i make in my book
that indeed sports music
all sorts of other fields language math
they they really do deliberate practices
if you have a seven or an eight-year-old
at home
how many times do they do the alphabet
right how many times do they do
small calculations under 100s hundreds
of times
so it's really true that we miss this
skill of deliberate practice
and if we do deliberate practice almost
always the deliberate practice is
programming
is writing that's stuff like advent of
code which is nice like nothing against
advent of codes
but it is producing code or people have
or
like should have right a site saturday
open source project they're working on
always the focus is if we practice the
practice is in writing
the assumption is that just writing more
will make you a better programmer
whereas as you say with music yeah
that's not really true
if you play an instrument you don't only
play
actual songs you also play tone ladders
and you do all sorts of
finger practice on the guitar so i
describe
a number of different exercises in the
book to do deliberate practice
one of the things i do i propose that
people do
is actually syntax training with
flashcards so like you would
train french for example you put an
english word on one side
like frog and then on the other side you
put the word in french
and then you practice you train yourself
this is something you can also do with
programming language concepts and
constructs if you are entirely new like
i've never done closure in my life
so if i would want to learn that then it
would be great a great way for me to
learn is to put
four state a for loop on one side in
python which i know
and then the equivalent on the other
side so that is
a way to get to know programming
concepts so
that the syntax doesn't get in the way
because
i think one of the mistakes that people
make especially if they transfer to a
second programming language
is they think that they can be experts
immediately i
i would be super annoyed if i am very
slow in making a for loop and
in getting data from an endpoint or
something
because this is an easy task it should
be an easy task but you really need a
little bit of syntax practice so that is
one of the
deliberate practices that i describe but
also for code reading we have whole
chapters on the on goat reading
with many specific exercises for example
um
if you are new to a piece of code you
haven't seen it or maybe you haven't
seen it for a while
just look at the code for a few minutes
and then you close your eyes or close
your laptop
and you just throw down okay what were
the things that
occurred to you what is the first thing
that occurred to you what is the second
thing that occurred to you
how are those things related what did
you notice in programming concepts
what did you notice in domain words
domain concepts
so that is a way to reflect on code and
again
this isn't just stuff i am making up
there's a very long history that we also
described in the book
about research into natural language
reading
if you have a teenager in high school
very often they would do these exercises
right they get a story
or a newspaper article and they have to
read it for five minutes and then they
have to put it away
and have to write down okay what did you
remember what was the story about
what is the main character those are
exercises of which
we know that they really support normal
text
natural language text comprehension and
so it's extremely likely that this is
also going to support
programming comprehension so uh
in your keynote that you did at strange
loop in 2019
one of the things i thought was really
fascinating was um the part about
vocalizing
uh syntax and and saying practicing
saying syntax out loud as you're
learning
and how important that is just like it
is with natural language
um and uh that was something i don't
think i've
ever heard anything about before and
it uh so i that was one of my favorite
parts of the talk
um and i was wondering if you could just
talk a little bit about
about that yeah absolutely so a part of
the memory that we haven't described now
in this chat but it is described in the
book
is called the auditorio auditory memory
so if you hear something it enters a
specific
part of your memory actually all your
senses have their own
little little mini story so there's also
a visual
memory that if you look at something and
you close your eyes
then you can still see it in a sense so
that is your
your visual memory and there's also
auditory memory
an example of this is suppose someone
this is a bit old-fashioned example but
someone calls you on the phone
and tells you a number a postal code or
something a zip code or
a good of a
database element that is corrupt or
something and you don't have anything to
write on
so you have to remember 5 4 7 a b
12 or something what you would do is you
would re
remind yourself in a in your silent
voice right you put down the phone
you're looking for a pen and you go like
4 5 8 b 12 4 5 8 b 12.
so that is your auditory memory and we
know from research that
the way words sound what happens in your
auditory memory
also very much influences what happens
in your in your thinking part for
example the example that i gave
in the talk at strange loop is if you
have people
read a sentence in which a word sounds
ambiguous for example if you have the
sentence
i have a tear and then
the next part is in my patents
and what happens is if you're reading it
you were like oh
that wasn't tear that was there you have
to go back
and repronounce the words in the correct
correct way
we did some experiments based on again
based on science that was already there
in other fields
we did some experiments in which we had
children vocalize
python codes we just had them read it
aloud we said just
imagine you have to do this homework on
the phone and you're telling your friend
that they have to type up the code
and we saw very interesting patterns
where kids
don't know how to vocalize characters if
if it's in
equal sign or in python you have equal
equal they wouldn't specifically read
equal equal it's sort of a weird way to
read so they would just skip
it and of course if you don't read it in
your inner voice
if in your inner voice you read if i is
five
instead of if i is is five later on if
you're typing then you might also not
use this inner voice to remind yourself
that you actually have to type to
consecutive equal signs because
otherwise the code doesn't work
so this vocalization this inner voice
that you use
is is very important in programming
and what we also found is as you are
also saying
no one has thought about this before as
far as we could
we really dove into existing science and
it doesn't seem to be the case that
other people have ever explored this
idea of
what do people hear if they hear code
and it's also super inconsistent so we
just had some studies in which we asked
professionals
to read some python code allows and then
they're super
not systematic about it so sometimes
they would say
um if you have i plus is one for example
they would say adds one or increase by
one or add one to the value so they're
very
not systematic which probably isn't a
problem if you're
already an expert but imagine i would go
to closure and i don't even know how to
properly
inner voice all the weird characters
that i don't know then that just takes
up extra energy so it would be great
if people communities get a sort of a
like a standard saying this is how we
call
those things like in in python you know
i have this new
operator then colon is
and they call this thing the walrus
operate right because it looks like a
walrus because it has teeth
firstly i we have no wall versus here in
this country so
i didn't even know why i always call the
walrus operator
so it's not very inclusive of people
that don't have walruses
but also it helps me in no way to
understand
what it does am i gonna say x wall
versus five
that's just a very badly chosen name
yeah i think about with with closure as
a lisp it's all
you know parenthesized nested
parenthesized expressions
and i have no idea how to read that in a
way that is useful to people
so i have thought about it some i
haven't come up with an answer yet but
i'm
i'm still thinking about it yeah
brackets were actually in the
experiments we did brackets were really
interesting
round brackets or parentheses because
some people would indeed say
if they were defining a function f takes
integer so they would really translate
it to the meaning if it's a function
definition
and then in function application people
would say f
of five so that's a that's a great way
actually
to vocalize parentheses uh in in
actually what they mean
but yeah if it's really an ast and a
lisp then
yeah how do you read it i wouldn't know
either
um another thing you you said in your
talk was
um you were talking about wanting to
start
start a pedagogical pedagogical fight
about um whole language versus phonics
type
things like explicit instruction versus
immersion
and this is something that i uh really
connected with because my
wife runs a dyslexia reading center and
and we have a dyslexic
child and um and i i hear her
doing phonic instruction all day long on
the on the computer so
i uh we are 100 fully on board with uh
phonic and explicit instruction because
that's the only way that uh
is really useful for dyslexic kids to
learn how to read
so i'm wondering if you if you how how's
it going how's the uh picking a fight
going
well actually i think in a sense my book
is also a continuation of that fight
because for example like the flash cards
training syntax
i say well that works if you're an adult
learning a second programming language
clearly that also works if you're a
child learning a
first programming language so the book
isn't really meant for educators but
many people of course in the programming
community are also programming educators
to their own kids or to the school that
kids go to
or encoder dojos or programming clubs
just because
there aren't so many teachers regular
teachers that know programming
many of the programming education also
falls on the shoulders of our community
so part of the fight is also i think in
the sprinkled in the book
in some ideas that might work for you
they also might work for your children
and also something else that's maybe
pretty interesting to talk about is
i made a programming language so i made
a programming language called hedy code
headycode.com and that programming
language
is also an implementation of the ideas
that i talked about already
in 2019 at strange loop so the idea
of heli is that it does teach
programming like it teaches
like we teach a natural language rather
than teaching
everything of python at once we teach
python in steps
we call this a gradual programming
language it's a little bit like gradual
typing
but then the syntax is gradual rather
than the types
so hedy has levels and in the first
level you can just you have like no
syntax
you just say python oh sorry prince and
then
hello world no brackets and no quotation
marks
so kids get used to oh this is
programming and this is why it's fun you
can already at level one
build a tiny interactive story without
any syntax
and then in the next step we say okay
but if you have no brackets
no quotation marks it's kind of hard for
the computer to know what is a variable
and what is text
so look we run into issues in this
programming language
because we don't have quotation marks we
cannot tell the computer
when we mean the string a string and
when we mean a variable name that we
want to have
we as an example we define name as a
variable
and then that's nice because then you
can use it in your interactive story
but then if you want to print my name is
name then you have to tell the computer
that the first name is a string
and the second name is a variable and so
then gradually every level
adds a little bit of syntax in addition
to also explaining why this syntax is
useful
i think heading is very much an
implementation of this idea
of phonics because if you teach a
natural language and if you have a
five-year-old
then you also don't say okay
five-year-olds are gonna learn how to
read here are all the rules
semicolons quotations exclamation marks
all the rules and sentences and
sub-sentences
and no you're just happy if they can do
a three-word
sentence it doesn't need to start with a
capital letter it's just
it's fine so in that same line of
thinking
we created hedy code which is free and
open source by the way so people can
just try it out for free
it's not like i'm selling anything apart
from the book of course
and and that is very much this phonics
implemented in a programming language
that's really interesting i did look at
it a little bit before the before we
got on so it it it is really interesting
um i also wanted to ask you about back
in 2014 you did a talk at strangely
about
uh spreadsheets and um your your love of
them and your belief that they are
programming
and i'm fully on board with that do you
do you still work on
spreadsheets on a regular basis or is it
more no
no i have a few grad students who are
still finishing their thesis work
like in my my old line of research so
i'm still
supervising a few students that work on
that but
my own main research interest now is
programming education
although i do think there are lots of
parallels between
people that are programming in
spreadsheets
and and kids in a sense one thing that i
really still take away
from my work on spreadsheets into my
work on programming for kids
is the idea that if you're an accountant
you are not interested
in programming you're interested in
getting your budget to be right
or getting your model to work you don't
care about programming
at all it is a tool and i think
so much of our community is built upon
the
idea that if you want to be a programmer
you have to love programming
and and not the goal but you have to
love the tool
like if you say something like well i
don't really care for programming i care
for making something with programming
then you're starting out group right
that's that's not the proper opinion in
a sense
and that is also true if you teach kids
some kids will really like programming
but some kids you have to tell them
why it's fun and this is also just
coming back to hedy a little bit
some of the introduction material i've
seen for kids
just assumes kids want to learn
programming probably because it's
written by adults that love programming
which
isn't a bad thing in a sense but if the
first
10 pages of your book are setting up a
virtual environment in python
and then the next 10 pages are yeah you
have to use
brackets and quotation marks and you
have to put space in the right
place you're only gonna make that
as a kid you're only gonna be willing to
invest in all of this
if you're really certain that this is
going anywhere
so if you're the type of kid that maybe
doesn't have a computer at home
doesn't know what can be achieved with
programming or if you're a girl
and many people in your younger years
have told you that programming is hard
and it's really for you and it's really
more for your brother
then maybe after your first few
disappointments you're like yeah this
isn't for me
or why why would i care and i think i
really still
when i'm teaching programming i really
do think of people in an accounting
department
that aren't they don't look i mean i
love formulas
in excel i think they're a work of
beauty but i feel like they are
they're it is like look at this formula
and look how beautiful
it is no it's just now it works i'm
happy moving on
and and you have to make sure if you're
teaching kids that you
have enough of those moments where they
make something
and they're like ah right i know
sam aaron also did a talk at strangeloo
and
one of the things i really liked with
the programming language that he made
sonic pie
this is a language with which you can
create music
and and his philosophy is that if kids
go to a
concert and they see someone like bob
dylan with a guitar
or with a piano then that's the tool
they can also have at home
they can also buy a guitar and start to
play it
so you want to have this thing that
feels real that feels like
like the real thing and i think that's a
that's a great philosophy
kids don't want to learn the guitar
because they like the thing
right they like the music it makes and
maybe they like the music
they see some people in dance like oh
that's what i want to learn and then
doing all the stupid down letters
that's boring right that's no that's not
fun it's just not fun to do
but it's so clear to them what they can
be what they can do
what they can achieve if they learn the
guitar that they are willing to put in
the pain
and i think that's that's something as a
programming community we're not
great at yet to explain kids like what
they can do all these examples and
i am so guilty of this as well but so
many of my examples
also in university i mean hello
undergrads you know what we're gonna do
print all the prime numbers
in retrospect i now know that this isn't
fun
for everyone i think it's really cool
but
why why care about them especially if
you know
in a broad undergrad programming like a
liberal liberal arts program
why do you want to prevent all prime
numbers there are infinitely many
like who cares so i'm really also in my
university teaching trying to turn that
around
into oh here's a piece of shakespeare
i'm gonna analyze what type of words
they use and how different is
shakespeare from
today's newspaper which you can also do
that with with two nested for loops you
can already do
a little bit of interesting text
analysis and then so some undergrads
might think oh
like this is a useful tool so if i want
to become a linguist if i want to do
analysis of written text then python
makes sense to learn a little bit more
about
and it's such a more inclusive way to do
stuff
yep i i've tried uh well i've
worked with kids a number of times and
trying to teach different things and
i always try to start with something uh
something that they
might want to do like you know pro
you know drawing things on the screen or
writing interactive fiction or
you know to tell a story or uh making
music
you know those are all the things i've
i've used to
get started in that um and that that
definitely seems to work better if you
connect
start from that and then and then the
other thing is the the sort of the
feedback cycle you know being able to
do something and see the result of it um
quickly
at the beginning seems like a a key
aspect of
of you know getting that little
you know endorphin hit from yeah yeah
change something and see a result you
know so
all right well that's all i had today is
there anything else you want to talk
about with the book or
um do you know when it's going to be
done or yeah oh yeah
yes i have to send it to the printer
mid-april so that is in six weeks i'm
mainly saying that as a reminder to me
that i have to finish it but there are
12 out of the 13 chapters have been
written so they will
slowly be added to the online book so if
people buy the online book now there are
now four chapters out
but every three four weeks a new chapter
will be released on the
in the early access program and then it
should be coming out
print somewhere in may excellent
well i look forward to reading the rest
of it i've only been able to see the
first few chapters of it but
uh so far it i thought it was
fascinating it's
uh i would i would definitely recommend
it thank you so much for
um for chatting today
yeah thanks for having me thanks
bye
you